[Music]
I'm Tyler and I'm gonna save a little
more time this is your at-home white eye
leg workout so we're gonna be doing a
white eye leg workout today I'm gonna
combine some kicks and stuff I'm
guessing yeah I mean you have leg
workouts that are designed to make your
legs physically bigger and stronger and
then you have muy Thai workouts the good
thing about Muay Thai in general is we
can do a little combination of both so
we're gonna be able to run you through a
variety of different drills designed
specifically to target your leg muscles
to make them a little stronger give you
a little more reaction time and to also
give a little bit of balance okay so
what are we doing the first thing what
we're gonna do first is a push kick in
general so I'll go into my fighting
stance which we've done before the
fighting stance so he's probably both of
our feet together and I turn it out 90
degrees
right well separation good and I just
need a little wide with my stance I take
my right hand I bring it right up to my
chin my left hand out in front of me I
want to make sure that I'm not blocking
my vision so I don't want to have my
hands tucked right here I'll kind of
want to have my hands out in front of me
a little bit and basically I bring my
leg up press forward and come back and
then I do that continuously but now I
don't want to go as fast as I can and
get out of balance you take your time no
rush okay keep your hands up and work on
bringing your leg up press forward and
come back boom nice and solid boom and
come back you want a little out of air
each of that then you can go knee strike
kick good remember remember you're
pressing that foot out okay take your
time
nice and slow almost like you're setting
your leg out good there you go good
shake it out now the thing about it is
you want to do them with both sides of
your body so you don't want to get a
habit of doing just one leg at a time so
now what we're gonna do is you're gonna
you switch your stance and you go in a
southpaw stance where you'd have your
right foot forward and you do the same
thing okay
good and retracting that foot is just as
important to be able to throw the kick
good just don't drop your hands until
that kick we can just modify that a
little bit in general okay we could
throw a side kick so what
I would do now is I'm gonna be sideways
you know what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
take this foot I must fly it to where
this foot is and I'm gonna step and kick
and come back good remember we're
pressing the leg out good pressing out
keep it up good go ahead and switch
relax for a second take a deep breath if
you need to last one good job go ahead
relax for a minute now we're gonna do a
little combination of a double knee
strike okay so what I like to practice
doing this thien's square okay and I'll
Drive one foot back I'll bring this knee
up plant the foot down and come back and
just knee back knee back knee back gonna
be a little difficult at first you'll
pick it up though okay here we go
so back knee first you'll fire that
right knee it'll come forward it comes
straight down that goes back boom down
and back take your time
how'd you tell that me lean back a
little bit good good job relax and
breathe so to recap on your whites high
leg workout we started off with the push
kicks alternating sides then we went
into the side kicks again alternating
sides and we finish up with the double
knee strike train like an athlete you
will look like an athlete it's easy as
that alright thanks Kim all right
[Music]
you
[Music]